you
what's up guys welcome to a special
edition of the live show we're here in
japantown in San Francisco for the 2012
j-pop summit the fourth annual j-pop
something to be exact and there's a lot
of things going on here a lot of street
food lots of things happening
unfortunately in Victoria is out
cosplaying and mingling and having fun
what cosplay friends while Patrick is
out getting it going to give you because
he just could not help them sell however
we are here at the kabuki hotel with our
will be the corresponding and she's
gonna be telling us more about a little
bit of culture as you guys know the line
shall we've covered a lot of different
things from Jay culture music to the
anime to the movies to the agricultural
aspect but we never be touched on what
the lolita culture is so Tiffany can you
just give us a brief example definition
of what the leader culture is all about
so basically it's a fashion as some
culture fashion that was from
I said 20 years ago from harju coupe so
it's inspired lead by Victorian Rococo
fashion like historical fashion you can
see like my the bell-shaped skirt and
like the blouse and everything I've been
eventually evolved to become just
something super feminine girly and sweet
so in a lot of fashion these days you
kind of see like it's all about you know
maybe looking sexy and stuff really is
like the complete opposite it's no
really cute almost like a princess you
know and so you actually brought on an
entourage of will leave us with you
today they're just like waiting in the
wings so we're gonna ask them a few
questions and figure out exactly what
the Lolita culture is all about first of
all welcome and what's your name my name
is Jennifer Jennifer and how did you get
involved in the Lolita culture now it's
kind of you know knew about it a little
bit just from you know watching anime
and stuff like it's kind of a popular
like you know Gothic Lolita is kind of
like it was trending for a little bit in
your an amazing style so I kind of knew
what it was but you know after my sister
started really you know getting into the
culture and sort of buying more of the
fashion I she started telling me oh you
know there's different subtypes you know
it's not necessarily always just the
classic black and white combination I'm
usually I tend to dress in more of a boy
style which you know like i mentioned
involves more of like shorts and like
maybe a vest and a hat thank you very
much for stopping on by and hope you
enjoy the rest of the experiment thank
you so much my name is Gwen and I really
love Allison the Pirates and today is a
special day at the j-pop summit and I'm
kitty which is actually the offspring of
Alice in Wonderland kitty so I really
had fun kind of using something cooking
an angel in my outfit and also choco
mint so it's really fun it's more casual
hi what's your name hi I'm Liz but how
do you usually like you know obtain
these outfits I like to get a lot of
things secondhand because you can save
money and also you can find pieces that
aren't in stores anymore
so what would you say to people who
don't know anything about the Lolita
culture to encourage them to become more
involved in it well there's a lot of
different styles so I think there's
something for everyone and everyone has
a different reason for a similar leader
so I'm sure you can find some way to
relate to it when it's on the dresser so
um so please introduce yourself come on
in a Shannon so what is your favorite
sup style oh my favorite is definitely
classic um especially over the top
classic so today is not very
over-the-top this is more like a country
sweet classic style I can you actually
define country sweet classic sound
because I mean a lot of people out there
may not know what that means um classic
style typically is more floral and also
a silhouette shape very elegant um with
sweet it's more like cute and country
has more um I don't know about polka
dots as a picnic thing huh yeah a picnic
theme and like you know teddy bears also
works with that I mean there's cakes as
well so it's like a mix of styles my
name is Christine okay and so how did
you get involved in the Lolita culture
Oh similar to a few others probably the
internet first so I know like personally
that you cosplay as well but um you know
a lot of people sometimes did not only
sure what's the difference between
cosplay and Lolita so you know what
would you tell someone who would say oh
isn't likely the same thing Oh for
costly you kind of pick your favorite
character to be as well as to make and
where people can identify exactly who
you are for Lolita even though all the
dresses are already made you can kind of
give your own style to it make your own
unique perspective of Lolita so it's not
just a straight copycat like cosplay
maybe because everyone know cosplay the
same character and have the same
elements but someone can take the same
elite address but have their own
accessories to it and make it their own
well anyways thank you very much for
stopping online and
we're gonna hop it on the live show with
us and hope you enjoy the rest of the
j-pop summit so that was really
interesting all those different
perspectives on the loot leader culture
and different style different styles and
how people get involved what was your
personal take them on all of this like
Oh personally you know i love the fact
that Lolita fashion i think is going
bigger yo just since I got into anal
we've had a couple of all brands coming
into camp just go open your story
awesome thank you very much never
sucking all by so guys this is tiffany
our lolita correspondence definitely
stay tuned for more like Joe action
coming your way just a hot second
you